to us to a certain extent
we've always tried especially the films
me and simon made
uh paul as well and cuban fury and
and then the ones i did with edgar and
simon it's
it was about making
us laugh and making our mates laugh and
and just a group of friends
who just wanted to have fun and make a
film and have a laugh and
you know we love zombie films and now we
get a chance to make our own zombie film
and we love cockfield and now we're
making hot fires and i think it was only
when
when we did the
the
work the american press tour for hot
fuzz
i think did we realize how successful
sean of the dead had been you know right
because it was like when we did our tour
for we did such massive press tours for
these films
you wouldn't do them these days but like
for sure of the day we did
28 american cities in 35 days or
something like that you know
and then for hot fuzz we did exactly the
same thing
and for world time funnily enough but
like
when we went to do sean of the dead we'd
come to introduce the screening
and no one would really clatten or would
know us and
you'd get a few people saying well a
space and
but then afterwards they'd love the film
so people would go bonkers right but it
was when we did hot fuzz when we had to
go and introduce the film every night
the cinemas were rammed
and everyone went absolutely mental
every time he went to introduce the
screening
and it was like wow you know people
love sean of the day
one of my favorites i've seen it a
hundred times i'm a big i'm a big horror
movie fan if you came to my house you'd
see return of the living dead fright
night evil dead posters that's just kind
of like who i am
you know yeah i love it yeah um do you
think that it's it's sort of like
do you miss that camaraderie that just
trying to make each other laugh on set
and then what happens is inadvertently
or ultimately you get famous and then
people start wanting you in their own
projects but now you're not working with
these same people who you
live off of and and rip off of and does
that kind of do you kind of like when
you're on another movie set you're
probably like i want every movie set to
be like shawn of the dead i want the
jokes to always be coming and they're
not always like that
yeah look i i'm gonna say no i mean
as much as i i mean i love working with
acre and simon and
i would be nothing without those films
and
and and without the the chance
and and the gamble that those guys took
on me as a performer you know never
having acted before
you know i i'm aware that i'd kind of
i'd be
i'd be the
area manager of six chiquito's mexican
restaurants right now but you know it's
it's also when you're friends like that
and the more films you do the more money
you get given to make the films the
pressure gets more and more and more so
right you know friendships creak it's
difficult you know